thousands of fans are heading to the las
vegas motor speedway for nascar weekend
jc fernandez at the track with a preview
of all of the fun
hey guys this is so exciting because the
gates just opened up here at las vegas
motor speedway the fans will be making
their way in for the first time in a
long time and this is jeff motley with
las vegas motor speedway
jeff you said earlier about 12 000 fans
will be here this weekend what does that
mean to the drivers having fans
i think having fans is a lot of
excitement you know it was pretty
depressing last september
for kurt bush to win in his hometown and
get out of the car and he's got no one
to celebrate with the drivers hear the
fans they hear before they get in the
car
they hear them when they get out i don't
think you can look any farther than last
monday night's hockey game the golden
knights
you saw the way the players reacted when
they won that game and the fans
i mean players want to put on a show for
the fans and that's what it's all about
and i think getting fans back just upset
adrenaline level a little bit too that
energy that energy let's take a look out
on the track and so the trucks what time
the gates just opened what time do the
trucks start tonight well the race is
going to probably green flag about 6 15.
we're going to sing the national anthem
at six o'clock
about 10 minutes after that we'll get
the commemorations from antonio williams
of the buffalo bills we'll be doing that
tonight
and then we'll probably be racing about
five seven minutes after that all right
let's take a walk with you this is cool
because it is sold out this weekend
but there's something very special for
everyone watching at home they can still
come down
and experience nascar in a very special
way i'm going to lance guide you over
here
to look over the rail into the parking
lot what an exclusive view do we have
jeff what are we looking at and how can
people experience this well you can
already see people
out there shopping at all the souvenir
rigs those open two hours before the
gates open
so they've been over open for quite some
time now so people can buy souvenirs
from their favorite race car drivers you
see a bunch of the drivers
rigs out there so uh you know you can
come and do that without even going
through the gates
it's awesome it's gonna be a fantastic
weekend nascar is back in
las vegas we got fans out here this
weekend the gates just opened out of an
official ticket so i think i have to get
out of here
jeff thank you so much for joining us we
appreciate it thank you for having me
and you guys back at the studio enjoy
the races this weekend send it back to
you